Спершу в Кремлі заявляли про те, що в ситуації в Казахстані головне - не втручатися
і що влада країни сама вирішить свої внутрішні проблеми.
А вже 6 січня перші російські десантні підрозділи були направлені до Казахстану як сили ОДКБ.
Із проханням про це виступив напередодні президент Токаєв.
Ситуація є зрозумілою: якщо є загроза стабільності Токаєву і з'являються люди,
які захоплюють владу, спираючись не на якісь внутрішні чи зовнішні ресурси,
то зрозуміло, що Кремль втрачає контроль над цією територією.
Політичний контроль, силовий контроль.
У цій ситуації йому просто нічого не залишається зробити, окрім як відгукнутися на пропозицію пана Токаєва і ввести туди війська.
Можлива втрата контролю над територією Казахстану, на думку багатьох аналітиків,
є лише однією із загроз для Кремля і лише однією з причин для втручання в ситуацію.
Казахстан - це незахищений кордон Росії. Для Росії це надзвичайно важливо,
особливо у ситуації різкого зростання нестабільності в Азії за межами пострадянського простору.
Політологи відзначають, що нинішній сценарій із залученням російських військових
до розв'язання внутрішньої кризи в іншій країні реалізується в новітній історії далеко не вперше.
Це, звісно, дивно і нагадує багато ситуацій, у які втручався Радянський Союз.
Варто згадати хоча б Чехословаччину. Це, звісно, політично та морально різні речі.
Але очевидно, що нинішнє керівництво Казахстану не може тримати ситуацію під контролем за допомогою своїх силових структур.
На тлі того, що увага Росії нині змістилася на Казахстан, деякі експерти припустили,
що це може знизити небезпеку російського вторгнення в Україну.
Утім, на думку оглядача DW, це не так.
Я думаю, що ці очікування не справдяться.
Я переконаний, що нинішні події між Сполученими Штатами і Росією готувалися Москвою заздалегідь.
Я думаю, що це не спонтанна операція.
Тому навряд чи події в Казахстані змусять Москву відмовитися від цих планів або якось послаблять її переговорні позиції.
Тому Росія поки що концентрується на дипломатичному фронті, веде переговори зі Сполученими Штатами і НАТО.
Я думаю, що навряд чи Москва відмовиться від ідеї отримати якісь гарантії щодо не вступу України
до Північно-атлантичного альянсу чи, можливо, застосування сили на Сході України
для того, щоб остаточно зупинити рух України на Захід.
Масові протести у Казахстані теж важко порівнювати з виступами проти влади
у Білорусі чи Україні, констатують оглядачі. І ось чому.
Головна відмінність подій у Казахстані від України, чи Білорусі,
чи навіть Вірменії останніх років або Грузії 2003 року -
тоді були дуже чіткі політичні вимоги від самого початку.
Як в Україні, так і в Білорусі, так і у Вірменії чи в Грузії.
Тобто "Майдан" - це було сильне повстання з політичними вимогами зміни влади.
У Казахстані ми цього поки що не почули дуже чітко.
Немає чіткого керівництва опозиційного.
Тобто ясно, що опозиція розгромлена, але тим не менше.
Немає опозиційних лідерів, які вийшли б і сказали: ми готові взяти владу у свої руки.
Тому це швидше нагадує бунт.
Протести у Казахстані стали реакцією на різкий стрибок цін на пальне.
Саме цей причинно-наслідковий зв'язок називав президент Токаєв, відправляючи уряд у відставку.
Проте згодом його риторика змінилася: у зверненні за допомогою до ОДКБ
він говорить про зовнішню агресію.
Терористичні банди є, по суті, міжнародними.
Вони пройшли серйозну підготовку за кордоном.
І їхній напад на Казахстан можна і слід розглядати як акт агресії.
Насправді це підрив цілісності держави,
і найголовніше це напад на наших громадян.
Без сліз на ці пояснення не можна дивитися.
Які іноземці це інспірували? Киргизстан чи що? Туркменістан? Туреччина? Та боронь Боже! …
А вже англійців та американців там і поготів немає.
Але в рамках того наративу, який існує на центральному телебаченні,
без зовнішнього втручання нічого не відбувається.
Тим часом відправка російських військ до Казахстану триває.
І тепер одне з питань - наскільки довгою буде їхня присутність у сусідній з Росією країні.